[Music]
I'm trying to do better just in case I
forgot my water bottle case you forget
your here's my fave yeah in case you're
great there we go look beautiful that's
why we did so your name is so unit here
it's Madelaine not a lame battle yeah oh
my parents are hippies and my lovin very
hippies we would eat from the garden my
parents are vegans very crazy little
little cookies but they my dad wanted to
name me street which if we can just
imagine for a second a poor little like
six year olds and I want your school
like gonna go walk down the street today
like people make so many jokes about it
well I'm a kid I named my kid River so
no we have to do lame like Lane on the
road madellaine street so there was like
a compromise you know I love your name
and I think it separates you out I think
Madeline is beautiful enough but
madellaine is it's gorgeous
thank you swells does Kelly well done
possible a lot of fun a lot of odd jobs
here in LA I did as well when I'm in
trapdoor high school yeah they did what
were what were would ask you but okay
you can ask me first
um six years ago I would go knock on
people's doors and like try to sell them
your windows Oh knocking their windows I
was a projectionist at the Malibu cinema
wait you were 13 years old yeah I know
it was chilly child labored what on
earth violation and but I but I put the
reels on in the wrong order Oh like my
jobs to put literally thread the
projector but man you screw that up you
definitely ruin the film it was over
yeah exam two my career you know what
maybe I'll just be in movies yeah that's
what you decide it was a better dream I
feel
so for Riverdale for people that don't
know it's about the Archie comics right
yeah I mean loosely it's really it's
just the characters of the Archie comics
and then everything else is different
like not being dead teenagers in the
Archie comics yeah your show is great
it's really very it's dark it's very
dark
you get darker by the day I think it's
like I'm in the clip you just saw I was
getting my poisoning your yeah normal
thing is you do as a teenager slightly
creepy but alright yeah my characters
probably the creepiest of them that's
kind of fun but it's so fun well the
villains are almost always more fun yeah
even if there's like not even much of a
villain thing happening in that scene
you still have that little yeah evilness
in your eye or whatever she's just sassy
- and like she's got this bite and fire
I love the villains and think my
daughter's favorite person Little
Mermaid is Ursula she just loves poor
unfortunate soul but so you started a
YouTube show - to try new things right
because I heard that although you grew
up around water you're like terrified of
water when I was in South Africa as a
kid I was in the sea as you do and a
tide got really big and it took me under
and I literally thought I was gonna die
I was 8 years old and my mom ran and
saved me apparently so my dad tells me
and so ever since then I've been kind of
scared of large bodies of water when I
booked Riverdale I you know you don't
get scripts when you audition for stuff
typically and I went to shoot it we just
got the script and I saw that I was
shooting in water I'm like oh I'm sure
it's a studio and a big deal they put me
in the middle of a giant lake in
Vancouver in a boat with somebody who'd
never owned a boat before it was so
scary I was totally fine I conquered my
fear which is why I started my new thing
called I try on you - yeah because after
doing something like that and being able
to conquer your fear it's a really great
way to push myself out of my comfort
zone I'm just and though right wait I
grew up around legs the legs can be
tricky because you can't see what's
happening
that's what freaks me had the ocean at
least you can see what's below you and
the lake you're like what dead body am I
I like your plate yeah all of a sudden
there's something called guard that
looks like a tiny alligator just like
swung by me
real real any water scary no I say in
the boat yeah that's great for not ones
that sink yeah actually I don't want to
go anywhere near water with you I've got
a bad luck with it so Rob have you ever
done anything that would get you would
you try something to get you out of your
comfort zone
are you I love getting out of my cover
some yeah are you yeah are you even
afraid of it you kind of try anything
I'm not afraid of mud the one thing I'm
afraid of and I do I love the water I'd
die if you dive I surf all of it ski
helicopter ski all of it
the one thing I don't want to do is
parachute I don't want to jump out of a
plane that I'm scared of that for summer
you know why because the plane is a
perfectly fine plane yes why kept saying
like if it's going down while your
chances are better jumping out with a
parachute so but yeah I don't get that
my sister did I was like you crazy to
try that maybe on the YouTube channel
you can try and I'll watch if you can
come to how to play I am NOT I love my
life I ain't like know that if I die oh
man subscribe to my channel subscribe to
my channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel please don't
make me keep going